hi I'm Erik Bosse and Godzilla king of
the monsters reminds is it really the
most fun thing about a monster movie as
always the monsters or kaiju Titans
whatever you want to call them certainly
more fun than anything smaller than a
building in this movie and even more so
than its predecessors Godzilla in 2014
and Kong Skull Island king of the
monsters really embrace that Toho
tradition with a ton of references and
easter eggs that were really easy to
overlook from hundreds of feet in the
air so let's go back through this movie
and break down everything that you might
have missed an spoiler warning in case
you haven't seen it yet okay the film
opens by introducing us to the Russell
family the mother dr. Emma Russell Vera
Farmiga her ex-husband Mark Coach Taylor
Kyle Chandler their daughter Madison
stranger things Millie Bobby Brown would
be survivors of Godzilla's past
destruction but still recovering from
the loss of their son mark and Emma are
an animal behavior specialist and a
paleo biologist who in this movie get
wrapped up in a wider plot to resurrect
ancient giant monsters and play God with
nature who ultimately come together to
save the kid very similar to the
scientist couple at the heart of
Jurassic Park actually the final shot of
Godzilla roaring as king of the monsters
is certainly parallel to the famous
t-rex roar at the end of Jurassic Park
with the when dinosaurs ruled the earth
banner and speaking of Spielberg
references the kaiju communication
technology that Emma and Mark have
created is called Orca the name of the
boat and Jaws Orca is named for the
sonar function of the endangered whales
that they were trying to save by leaving
them away from the shore which is
actually what Godzilla will later do
with the various kaiju in the epilogue
of the movie leading them from these
shorelines around the world this time to
protect endangered humans early in the
movie and news report shows protestors
with signs like kill the Titans and
destroy all monsters the second of which
is a reference to the title of the 1968
Toho film in which Godzilla and all the
kaiju team up to defeat King Ghidorah
Emma and Madison are revealed to be at
monarch outpost 61 in China's Yunnan
rainforest this is where the larvae form
of Mothra has been discovered
Mothra is the next famous kaiju from the
Toho films a benevolent gentle giant who
often teamed up with Godzilla to fight
other threats such as the main villain
of this movie King Ghidorah the
three-headed monster and evil kaiju with
extraterrestrial origins who breathes
light
with the wingspan so massive it can
create electrical storms there's also
Rodin based on the Pteranodon who's kind
of a rogue switching allegiances between
whoever is alpha now the Godzilla movies
were originally made to reflect the
Japanese fear of destruction during the
nuclear age with Godzilla being a
metaphor for the Americans following the
bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
Ghidorah was interpreted as the growing
threat from China and Rodan as the
threat from the Soviet Union also all
the outposts numbers in this movie are
references to the release years of those
total films here in China outpost 61
refers to 1961 when Mothra came out
there's also 55 the release of Godzilla
raids again 67 some Godzilla 75 terror
of Mechagodzilla and 91 Godzilla vs.
King Ghidorah Millie Bobbie B's stranger
things co star Randy havens plays dr.
Tim Mancini another monarch scientists
observing Mothra whose code name is
revealed as missourah the original
Japanese name of the character Mothra
freaks out against the soldiers but she
restrains violence tossing them around
pinning them to surfaces with webbing
but not eating them crushing them or
impaling them already we're seeing how
she's a gentle giant and when Emma calm
sir with the Orca the music that plays
is light motif by composer Bear McCreary
- the classic Mothra theme music
actually comes back throughout the movie
along with of course the classic
Godzilla theme music Emma and Madison
join eco-terrorist Allen Jonah played by
Charles dance Tywin Lannister from Game
of Thrones and in Washington DC we meet
more of this films the expansive cast
dr. Sam Coleman Thomas Middleditch he's
a monarch liaison of course Ken Watanabe
returns as dr. Serizawa from the 2014
film along with David Strathairn as
Admiral stints and Sally Hawkins as dr.
Graham the scientists find mark and take
him to Castle Bravo in the tablet that
Mark swipes through shows all the other
guides you in the movie mercy codename
Scylla
perhaps a nod to the Scylla from Greek
mythology in this movie it's a giant
Iraq deadlight kaiju that rises from oil
fields in Arizona and the spider-like
kaiju is based on the spy guy or kou
Munga from the Toho films the
there's also behemoth with huge tusks
which breaks loose from a monarch
containment facility Brazil later on in
the movie and then of course there's cog
on Skull Island
he gets referenced several times
throughout this film and then Methuselah
who later rises from the hills of
Germany a forest grows on his back and
there's various others in Loch Ness
Scotland
there's codename Leviathan a nod to
Nessie and Morocco there's Baphomet
which could be named after the goat
headed demonic entity worshiped by cults
and associated with the Knights of
Templar and in Sudan there's Mikael a
bimbe which is an elephants brontosaurus
type creature whose name means one who
stops the flow of rivers in Cambodia
there's Thai Fionn a nod to the Greek
myth snake monster in South America
there's ketse coddle based on the
feathered serpent deity of Mesoamerican
culture in North America there's a imact
another mythological sea dragon and
elsewhere on screen throughout this
movie there's a bat in Sargon and bun
inside Castle Bravo there's actually a
frozen head of one of the Muto's from
the 2014 film that can be seen probably
the female since his head was blasted
off in that movie but also in this movie
there's a new third female that shows up
if you're looking closely we also made
some more human characters Jackson
Barnes of the G team played by O'Shea
Jackson jr. and Bradley Whitford is dr.
Rick Stanton a wisecracking conspiracy
theorist who drinks a lot the director
confirmed that Rick is based on Rick
Sanchez from Rick and Morty who of
course is also a sarcastic alcoholic
conspiracy prone scientist Zhang Zi he
plays dr. Eileen Chen revealed later to
be a twin with her sister Lin Chen also
played by the same actress we find out
that these twins are from three
generation of twins which is of course
an amazing nod to the Mothra fairy
priestesses the show Jen from the Toho
films Jonah and Emma ahead to outpost 32
in Antarctica where monsters zero
Ghidorah is frozen in ice now Ghidorah
is extraterrestrial origin and this
outpost number could be a nod to John
Carpenter's The Thing in which an evil
extraterrestrial monster was frozen in
Antarctic ice near outpost 31 in that
movie the Marne our team follows them on
their flying command center the Argo
which is the nod to Jason and the
Argonauts of Greek myth the crew who
faced many of these mythological Greek
monsters that inspired the kaiju that I
mentioned earlier Jonah's team
resurrects Ghidorah from the ice
and the ensuing battle kills dr. Graham
when the monarch team realizes that mo
was in cahoots with Jonah sharing his
day a nurse did nothing wrong style
eco-terrorist mindset that worldwide
genocide is the only way to stop
overpopulation and climate change they
head to isla de Moura in Mexico where
Rodin is awakening from a volcano the
air battle is pretty incredible we see a
pilot ejecting directly in a row Dan's
mouth favorite shot of the film in
Admiral stands fires an oxygen destroyer
at the bat slain kaiju which kills all
the living creatures in the region but
doesn't kill Ghidorah of course the
oxygen destroyer was also the name of
the deadly device created by dr. Daisuke
AIDS Serizawa to kill Godzilla in the
very first movie of the franchise in
1954 Mothra rises from the waterfall
seen by the other doctor chin and Joe
Morton whose plane dr. Houston Brooks an
older version of Corey Hawkins character
from Kong Skull Island they find out
that Godzilla has returned deep into the
ocean to rejuvenate with radiation in
the ruins of a submerged ancient city
which isn't spelled out explicitly but
this is most likely the ruins of
Atlantis we don't get to see it because
it gets nuked unfortunately but it's
pretty cool in the background of these
ruins there's a statue of the demon
Pazuzu from The Exorcist films there's
also a giant ribcage near the entrance
of this air pocket which could be a nod
to another ancient Godzilla from the
past that might have died while fighting
Ghidorah which is kind of similar to the
past Godzilla corpse that was laid with
Muto eggs
Serizawa sacrifices himself by carrying
the warhead personally into the
radioactive hot spot which is a nod to
his namesake sacrifice in the original
1954 film Daisuke Serizawa sacrificed
himself to kill Godzilla but here is
Shiro Serizawa sacrifices himself to
save Godzilla and right before he says
in Japanese goodbye old friend he checks
his pocket watch and it reads 8:15 now
8:15 is precise minute that the atomic
bomb exploded over Hiroshima on the
morning of August 6 1945 they're
actually famous examples of pocket
watches being found frozen in time at
the moment of the blast so with this
sacrifice to awaken Godzilla
Serizawa once again reminds us of the
historical symbolism of the Godzilla
character by having to resurrect
Godzilla and drag him back into the
fight this movie paints Godzilla with
the personality of the Last Samurai
archetype the ancient lone warrior
contented retire
nice elation but his high moral
character forces him back into the world
to set things right the showdown arrives
in Boston with Madison using the stolen
orca to stop the kaiju destruction but
attracting King Ghidorah to Fenway Park
a supercharged Godzilla arrives to fight
Ghidorah but Godzilla's extreme
radiation has turned him into a Libyan
nuclear meltdown it's actually similar
to the main plot point of the 1995 film
Godzilla vs. destroy ahah which unlike
the other films being a metaphor for
nuclear annihilation this is more of a
metaphor of the fear of leaks at nuclear
plants like Chernobyl which by the way
watch that HBO miniseries it's amazing
or the disaster that Japan would later
experience at Fukushima Mothra arrives
to assist Godzilla with a screech that's
actually a modified version of her
iconic original sound from the Touhou
series and if you notice her wings have
by spots that were actually designed to
resemble Godzilla's eyes so that the two
kaiju are visually connected to reflect
their alliance this battle is
spectacular get Tora bites power cables
to supercharge with electricity
Godzilla blasted with atomic breath and
after getting dropped to the earth
Mothra heals Godzilla with their wings
and then sacrifices herself to black
adores lightning attack so just as the
queen of monsters sacrifices herself the
human maternal figure sacrifices herself
with Emma taking the Orca device and
luring Ghidorah away from the others
after going nuclear
Godzilla breaks apart kajoor his body
and some swallowing its head and
releasing a little lightning burp
amazing the other kaiju arrived and
grovel at Godzilla's feet as the Sun
rises on a new reign and in the credits
of the film we learn how king of the
monsters will set up the next movie
godzilla vs kong coming in 2020 there
are news headlines describing godzilla
leading the kaiju away from the mainland
toward Skull Island perhaps as a kind of
Exile away from the humans to protect
people but that could set up a power
struggle between Godzilla and Kong now
Kong is a lot smaller than Godzilla last
time we saw Kong but that was also
decades ago so who knows how large he is
now or with this movie's post-credits
scene featuring Alan Jonah finding a
severed Ghidorah head maybe the
resurrection of Ghidorah perhaps an
mecha king ghidorah form could be a
threat that Kong and Godzilla team up
against there's also a headline
describing a mysterious egg being
discovered most likely sitting
the resurrection of Mothra in the next
film and one last detail that you might
have caught that I thought was really
fun the scrolling credits listed
Godzilla Mothra Rodin and King Ghidorah
in the cast of the movie plane
themselves comment down below with your
favorite moment from this movie and
follow me on instagram and on twitter at
a vas subscribe to new rock stars thank
you for joining me and hey to all the
critics who are really going after this
film just remember that many of us grew
up seeing a version of Godzilla on the
big screen that somehow tiptoed across
the Brooklyn Bridge and squeezed inside
Madison Square Garden to do what yeah
lay eggs the male Godzilla laying eggs
yeah we've come a long way